good morning Millennials welcome to
another episode of snitch on the toast
hey switch on the toast
snitch on the toast hey switch on the
food it's always a bittersweet occasion
when it's a snitch on the toe situation
because while I love hosting with you it
always means that you know maybe
something is amiss with Claudia if she's
not on tour because you would be with
her then it's true this is true Claudia
is still sick she's on the mend and
according to her calculations she should
be back tomorrow yeah but I don't want
to jinx anything we just like her health
is what's most important here she got
she got some some nice antibiotics that
are finally kicking things into high
gear
so she texts like a [ __ ] doctor
yesterday and she like was by no means
okay and then she got her antibiotics
and then she texted me at like 9:00
she's like I'm 50% better and I was like
okay well greats majors try yes no she's
very a very sad sick person oh my god
she literally is like it's not funny but
like did not stop crying like so it was
so sad and like I felt that you know
what I mean it's like there's nothing
you can do your throat is [ __ ]
clothes it just can't stop crying but
the kindest makes it worse because then
you have just so much saliva and then I
found out yesterday that Theo was also
so sick yeah he because at first I was
like you live with a doctor like how was
this happening having a prescription
right what's the big whoop but then he
was sick she woke up to his puddles of
vomit so they're just like a sick house
oh my god I'm not stepping foot and it's
so sad but things are better we're just
you know rooting pretty I better maybe
she's watching it's definitely not
definitely not like literally I was
thinking maybe yesterday she would watch
it felt bad
no like whatever story yeah no no nada
well we have such a great show for you
today because not only do we have Nick
vile coming and I don't know today just
feels like really pertinent day for him
to come because we have a lot of
bachelor news and the Fast Five stories
but also we have such great Fast Five
stories and you know I don't I don't say
that lightly
oh yes Jackie's very interesting
interesting Fast Five stories they're
not exactly what you would think no
there's one that
not what you would think but I found
quite interesting full of interesting
factoids and we'll get to it eventually
also my presets launched today my summer
pack I'm so excited
per usual these are the presets that
I've been using just to get that jackieo
flow and if you don't know jackieo flow
means that like each picture looks as
best as it possibly can
yeah and that's the flow that's what I
was using for all of Aegeus I'm really
into ocean oh really yes it's because
it's so blue it's made for the blue
skies and the blue waters and the blue
eyes I guess I really like claudia was
loving enhanced from her bacon hands is
great too and I was loving worse natural
light for the pool party pictures
whereas natural light is a crazy filter
because it's like four one bad not sure
light doesn't even cut it it's like four
terrible situations however if you put
it on a picture with even like decent
light you'll look insane so usually need
every yeah use yes very lean
totally so that's exciting head to
Jackie O flow calm to check them out you
know per usual they'll be up forever
more I don't know I have no plans on
taking them down I would you I don't
know but yeah everything's available but
some because we always do things like in
drops yeah you know should take your
time check out the YouTube tutorial you
know check out my page I'll be posting
befores and afters all day long on my
Instagram and Jackie oh problems so do
you guys you like welcome back count
thanks sis how's it going it's going
good yeah nothing crazy since I saw you
12 hours ago yeah that's true oh we went
to a comedy show last night he called me
first comedy show in a while that hasn't
been our sister no I think my first
comedy show ever that hasn't been my
sister oh not mine but my first coming
to my Marlee two years because now that
my sister is a comedian I don't go and
check out other competition yeah yeah
but our best friend Kristin's fiance
Pete is a comic he was headlining at
Caroline's and we went and it was so
funny it was so funny it was just like a
premium stand-up experience so if he's
ever rolling through your town make sure
to check him out people Adele people
Adele it was really special playlist is
just as good oh yeah he posted a Lincoln
is I know anyway hide to my story where
I said that Kristin definitely made it
and he was like no it was me but I
definitely had to put some tailor sort
of deep cuts on there and I was like
nice thanks bro you
it was it's cool it's so like
interesting to have a friend who's a
comedian guess that's how people feel
about Claudia and now it's like you know
obviously the community's like [ __ ] on a
lot of things that other people do and
now it's like I hope I've never done any
of those things so sorry I do you have
an update
I'm from yesterday this is why we can't
have nice things because everyone all
season is asked not to batch of every
cat do it and I was like I don't want to
I go please let Margo do a recap and I
said time and time again I don't post it
on my story when I'm watching I don't
say anything because my mission is to
not have it spoiled so yesterday after
some [ __ ] I guess watched the show I'm
just like I'm feeling like a [ __ ] today
and she hmm like it wasn't I didn't post
about that's right she literally didn't
even reply to one of my stories it was
just a message you know so she had to go
to my profile we had never had any past
anything she has never applied to
anything goes to my profile messages me
and says blank wins and I literally was
like are you kidding me
I'm there I was so mad like on the brink
of like [ __ ] like and I didn't out
her because last time that this happened
to me I outed the person and they got
death threats and I had half the
followers I was like you know what I
don't want that pit I'm good yeah the
girl oh and then the girls who ruin it
that was Cassie last time message me she
was like so what I ruined it for you you
outed me but this time I did knows like
she's still following you and I was like
you're forgetting the part where you you
spoiled it for me then - like what's
wrong with people like like am I crazy
no or are they just insane I can't leave
that girl still follows you after you
send death threats to her door and
advertently and i'm sure like you like
yelled at her and she so follows you I
think she unfollowed me then like this
could the girl for me and she just
couldn't she kept coming back for more
in that sample and she the girl from
yesterday I didn't I didn't block right
in anything her but she blocked me as if
I did something wrong look that is so
crazy
I'm so sorry snitch here's
that's making me feel a lot better
everyone literally everyone and this has
never happened replied to my story being
like nobody really knows who wins
reality Steve might be wrong this season
I have seen a theory about every single
person winning so every no one really
knows I wouldn't makes me feel better so
I'm still holding out hope that like oh
oh and then she writes back to me when I
said I was like wow it's like two pieces
show she goes Jake a kissy face
I go I read I wanna kick her back sure
Dan I like to kick her count ok such a
good joke you're joking yours
backtracking whatever I got this are as
you need to get that out but like good
that was my update so next time when I'm
so angry or not this snappy because one
next time when I'm keeping my weekend up
shut now you know why this is why we
can't have nice podcasts snatch the rat
dead in the water
think about it counts yeah I'm thinking
about it I'm thinking damn damn I'm
sorry that happened to you that's the
price you pay about being a morning show
host you know yeah but like I was just a
temporary one you were just a temporary
one you were a temp I was a tenth and I
still got screwed screwed I'm so sorry
well if you're watching [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you that felt good yeah good
she was definitely watching yes oh my
god she was like today's my day today's
her day she did it so that this would
happen but you know what I'm so glad
we're not saying her name cuz nobody
knows who you are and nobody wants to
and nobody cares okay
well I feel as though it is time for us
to deliver the fast five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
because there's just so much to dig into
and there is a lot of bachelor news so
we'll be able to just keep talking smack
also I would be remiss if I did not tell
you that today's episode is sponsored by
Felix gray because we love them so much
and we really want to encourage you to
get that blue light out so eyes out so
that's their new slogan get that blue
light actual eyes we're like being extra
crazy yeah I think that one time yeah
what was that I don't if you did a
podcast episodes so it's just the couch
vibe oh yes well there's no today it's
the throne vibes
you may not realize it but the average
American blasts their eyes with bright
screens for 11 hours every day when you
consider how much our day revolves
around our devices it doesn't seem so
crazy between work scrolling through
social media
downloading Jackie O flow using your
presets on on photos to see how you
could have edited them and then leading
a life of regret the fact is we can't
eliminate extensive screen time from our
lives but you can't protect your eyes
with it from from it with a pair of
Felix grey blue light filtering glasses
available in both non prescription and
prescription Felix gray glasses filled
out 90% of high energy blue light and
eliminate 99% of glare coming from your
daily barrage of screens
unlike other blue light filtering
glasses Felix gray uses proprietary blue
light technology embedded into the lens
as opposed to a cheap coating that can
easily chip or scratch over time their
frames are handcrafted from the same
quality materials used in high-end
designer frames like organic Italian
acetate someone say Italian and German
engine eats engineered steel don't go
another day looking at screens without
the help of some Felix grades go to
Felix gray classes dot-com slash toasts
for free shipping and 30 days of
risk-free returns or exchanges that's
Felix gray glasses comm slash toast
felix great glasses calm sasha toast
sign-on see amazing ok well now it's
time now it's time our first story is it
one of the big stories of the day Sarah
Hyland and Wells Adams are engaged I'm
very happy for very happy for them
once again the wind was taken out of my
sails on this story because I've been
seeing speculation about it leading up
to this from their trip because she was
wearing an engagement ring because they
weren't engaged while they were on
vacation right because I saw it in the
toasters you know oh they were already
worth speculate and they were saying
like eh because it looks like she was
wearing a red you see that he said like
I don't know I think this might have
been an old comment but like about
whenever he did him and her did get
engaged she was like the money will be
coming out of my bank account I will be
paying for a oh it was Lorraine Schwartz
oh that's so now I know she deserves
deserves that
Wow the Modern Family star announced on
Instagram on Tuesday that she and her
boyfriend Wells Adams are engaged
quote that candy can't sleep reach for
the stars over the fence world series
kind of stuff she captioned the suite
gallery post referencing a quote from
mary-kate and Ashley
1995 movie it takes two that is [ __ ]
in tune with what's necessary a rep for
Hyland confirmed the engagement news to
page six adding the milestone moment did
not occur on the same day as their
social media posts which if you are a
toaster you already know in the series
of photos Hyland showed off her
engagement ring against a beautiful
beach backdrop while Adams posted a
video of the proposal that also included
a montage of photos of the couple
throughout their relationship quote I'll
be Johnny you be June but forever Hebert
of the video using a lyric from drew
Holcomb and the neighbors I love you too
Pluto and back fiance Hyland commented
on the photo super cute I haven't seen a
photo of the ring so now I need to go
stock Oh Oh gorgeous oval let me see
obviously I love it I love them they
seem super happy super normal like I
literally not a bad thing to say not a
bad thing to say it feels like they've
been dating the perfect amount of time
yeah and it just seems super like you
know logical next step super healthy and
I just like I love this for him I love
this for her
he is really just elevating The Bachelor
to new height to new heights in every
way like not even just a sarah hyland
way like just like he's the [ __ ]
bartender on bachelor in paradise do how
many people have gone on the show and
have never gotten that opportunity nope
I've never thought of it it was his idea
oh it was so entrepreneurial
entrepreneurial you know and like he had
a girlfriend so it's not Hakeem is gonna
go on paradise but he's also like a
smart guy
yeah and he's funny he's funny he's
well-spoken people love him he's been on
the show and he was great and I'm so
here for them and I look forward to
seeing their journey continued me too
like now we get a wedding I know I love
that so long actually no Lauren Inari it
was in January yeah but that was a small
wedding was it is in Hawaii I know but
that's like small destination but we
have a few coming up we have Rachel and
Brian right um Jared and asked she
should be getting married soon right
yeah cuz they're actually like planning
they've been engaged for a year now
because they got engaged in Paradise
last year right but weren't they dating
for like just say a few months yeah
within a year-long engagement it's a
little disproportionate it makes no
sense but like I'm sure they just have a
lot of planning to do and I think
they'll have a TV wedding I think
they'll have a TV wedding to a foreshore
I don't think Rachel and Brian will know
but it did look like she was filming
some stuff she might be doing like a
road to the altar sore
thing oh but on you thing on television
I do not digital I don't know I just saw
on her Instagram stories and like we
have the same wedding planner Mikey is
planning her wedding too and I just seen
like some video cameras started so if
something is documenting the process
which I'm here for because I just can't
get enough rain to Lincoln intent I like
it enough right - Lindsey content in my
life like I like wish I liked sports so
I could like listen and watch every
single thing that she does know I know
say it's like annoying and then Joe Jon
Jordan like they're definitely not like
they're definitely get married
eventually I'm just like not holding I
hope that it's soon because I just don't
think it is I don't think that it is so
busy
did you see their CNBC show that's good
yeah yeah no like they're busy they
can't get married right now but like I
think that they're steady and solid I
know so why not get married I just feel
like they're busy like renovating houses
I feel like for a long time they weren't
busy though they grace got busy
they just got busy but for that long
time they had to like fall in love again
there's like I think that once it was
over like she was over it and then I
think they had to find their way back
and so that's what they were like they
really were dating for that year of
engagement I think but it's been two
years two years
- no so - is Rachael Lindsey one is
Becca three is Jo Jo hmm interesante
Terris aunt they've been together three
years now and they're like that's yeah
we're ready to go
I really love them I think she's so
pretty like I know you love her I love
her
are you gonna watch cache pad um maybe
actually do love that HDTV stuff do you
yeah it's very like fixer-upper so like
I will watch one episode and if it
doesn't make me cringe then though then
they have me and then what about Becca
and Gary everyone's giving updates on
these couples oh I thought they were
gonna get married quickly - I haven't
heard like anything about them like
pining or anything yeah they seem so
crystal and Kris got married on parent I
think I'm married on paradise status
you're making me sad stop okay cool
there's a lot of good couples coming
down the pike I know it's hoped that
they never gonna break up in a while no
right whose last one and Shawn was last
one that was a brutal one for everyone
yeah but she bounced back like Little
Mix yep
okay next story exciting news for you
know the Academy
2019
nations are here Game of Thrones
dominates the HBO drama landed 32
nomination setting the record for the
most Primetime Emmy nom for a show in a
single year can a show get an e got
probably but well how would it get a
Tony unless they took it to Broadway
well the putting wouldn't could it get
enough is that a thing like I don't
think like who would yeah I'm sure one
movie or poncho could win all of those
awards and be considered it doesn't make
and it doesn't get credit to one person
because like right so so show it would
be just on the list of egos as a show I
don't know counts you're onto something
yeah because I gave me Thrones could
totally be doubted like they can win an
Oscar there's definitely on movies that
could have done all for like if greatest
showmen comes to a Broadway when it does
it has an Oscar no it didn't win the
song the song [ __ ] what is it Oh Coco
I still haven't seen it but I still want
to know I don't want to like no okay mmm
so some of the nominations drama series
better call Saul bodyguard Game of
Thrones killing Eve Ozark Poe's
succession this is us okay I watched a
Richard matter that inverses Game of
Thrones I watched a few episodes of
succession like waiting for it to be the
next dynasty and it was such trash and
like I was dying to like it because I
was in a desperate place so how is it
the best drama I am I missing something
did I not give it enough time of my life
I have never even heard of it
oh my god this is making Babbitt no I
don't think so this is an episode of
Breaking Bad there's a fly I've never
seen Breaking Bad a time episode comedy
series bury fleabag the good place
marvelous miss Mazal Russian doll shits
Creek deep shoots great that would be
epic of shits Creek one I want to see if
Moira Rose was nominated for a Emmy
because she deserves it she was good
lead actress in a comedy series oh my
god she has to win she's up against
Christina Applegate and dead to me
Rachel Brosnahan marvelous
Mazal Julia louis-dreyfus beep natasha
Lyonne Russian doll Feeny
Phoebe Waller bridge from fleabag okay
honestly I feel like it could happen
yeah Wow now tell me who was nominated
for name of thrones lead actress in a
Drama Series Emilia Clarke she was sorry
I made a boy yeah you didn't make up a
lie lead actor in a Drama Series Kit
Harington from Game of Thrones
but I saw that sophie sophie Turner was
nominated for supporting supporting
interesante okay I really hope she
wouldn't that would be epic but I think
it's her versus Maisie and like a bunch
of people supporting actor and in John
ruse oh wow the whole cast of Game of
Thrones Alfie Allen Oh Nikolaj
coster-waldau Peter Dinklage so three of
them okay and then Supporting Actress
Gwendoline Christie Lena Headey sophie
Turner Maisie Williams okay and then
Fiona Shaw and Julia Garner but so it
has to be a game of Thrones person who
would you I think it's really between
Sophie and Lena you think but she killed
the goddamn night quick my king Arya
but just because her actor had a great
like just cuz her character had a great
moment doesn't mean that the acting like
not good she's a bad actress if anything
honestly and I would say Lena yeah
because she made me [ __ ] hate her
yeah she's a great actress
yeah like I thought I want Sophie I want
so he's acceptance speech oh my god or
she brings the jewel up to the state and
she's like oh my god that's why please
that's why they have to get any of your
parents or sibling or on grandparents
are on the board please they have to
give a turn oh my gosh okay now that
makes me excited maybe I'll watch the
Emmys just yeah I'm gonna watch the
Emmys show so I can see see the cast's
okay well most of these shows I don't
watch that are like nominated for a lot
of stuff but seems exciting for everyone
involved
everyone seems happy others show scoring
multiple Emmy nominations included
marvelous miss Mazal 20 sure noble 19
you guys if you haven't watched I'd
watch it and this is so pertinent to the
situation SNL 18 Barrie and phosphor
dawn 17 apiece Netflix is when they see
us 16 and click here to see which
shows and talents were snubbed okay
unbreakable kimmy schmitt the good fight
Tracee Ellis Ross and Allison Janney I'm
sorry those are two people that you just
can't sub these are snubz
those are snubz Kimmy Schmidt snot a
snub sorry but like the last season was
weird get I mean it art yeah it's over
yeah it doesn't meet need to be
nominated for Emmys anymore
sweet well I don't know when the Emmys
are you neither but I don't know they
got announced in the summer on September
22nd okay that's in five months so it's
like in a month and a half how scary is
that that's so scary like soon it will
be September 22nd we're talking about
who won the Emmys and I'll be thinking
back to this episode no but it's really
in like two months that's true and
that's a long way away that is a long
way away a lot can happen yet people got
to get campaigning making posters oh
yeah oh yeah okay are you ready for our
next story because it's really sad no
it's not throwing that you know okay
that's your creator Mike Fleiss accused
of attacking pregnant wife Laura Fleiss
the wife of Bachelor creator Mike Fleiss
has filed a temporary domestic violence
restraining order against him claiming
he attacked her after demanding she get
an abortion quote while mike has been
frequently has frequently been verbally
abusive towards me during our marriage
in recent weeks he has become enraged
due to the fact I am pregnant with our
second child the docs obtained by page
six via the blast reads who Mike told me
many times that he did not want us to
have a second child
he also repeatedly told me throughout
our marriage and prior to our marriage
that he knew he would quote have to have
one child with me because I was 26 years
old when we got married did not yet have
any children and he knew I wanted to
have a family according to the docs
which were filed by her attorneys on
Monday on July 4th while vacationing at
their home in Kauai Hawaii the reality
TV producer allegedly quote demanded
Laura got an abortion and threatened he
would end their marriage if she didn't
comply Laura 31 also claims Mike 55
threatened to cut her off financially
and told her she could quote have an
abortion or go back to Wisconsin but
couldn't take their four-year-old son
Ben he continued to threaten me
demanding to see bank statements showing
I paid for an abortion and the flight
information to and from Oahu for the
medical procedure she stated on July 6
Laura who submitted photos from an
outdoor surveillance camera
the alleged incident says Mike became
physically abusive while she was in bed
with their son who was sick he allegedly
came in and forcibly grabbed her phone
out of her hands so there are some
photos from what looks like a security
camera outside the house and inside the
house that are really disturbing what I
attempted to grab my phone back from
Mike that I was not able to do so Mike
exited the bedroom and rushed to the top
of the stairs I followed him trying to
get my phone back from him and he yelled
that he was going to quote shove me down
the stairs the declaration reads just
before we got outside of the front door
he grabbed my body forcibly pinned me up
against the wall and held me there after
I broke free he continued to use his
arms and hands to aggressively push me
away from him as he walked outside the
door still not returning my phone she
says he then shouted I'm going to punch
your face in the alleged argument
continued until Mike left her with her
phone Laura states that she then had a
neighbor Drive her and her sent to a
friend's house and then went to the
police station she filed a report at the
time but declined an emergency
protective order okay this story is like
so disturbing so serving and it's just
so upsetting and I like we've known that
my place is a piece of [ __ ] like for a
while like I don't know he was the
fiscal abusive right I didn't know he
was like this level piece of [ __ ] yeah
um so it's it's upsetting and I hope
that ABC takes the necessary measures
because this is unacceptable it's
unacceptable and like I understand you
created the bathtub or like you can you
can fire him and you can bring someone
else and it's it's not a big deal it's
really not a big deal it's it's time for
him to go it's been time for him to go
for a long time yeah bye he's it seems
as though he's always been problematic
and like anytime he's portrayed in like
fictional TV characters like uh none
real yeah it's just a real [ __ ] of a man
I'm sure there's also so much we don't
know
yeah so I'm here for the takedown of my
place I think it's and I feel really
sorry for the wife it's this time time's
up for my place yeah time's up
Hondo pee so I think the reckoning is
obviously here um this is like so beyond
I [ __ ] up though I know also like
you're married and she's pregnant should
be an amazing thing like wait a monster
what a monster I can't guess ABC anyone
in the camp made a state I haven't seen
and I was actually surprised cuz
yesterday I saw it in the toaster it was
written up by the Inquisitor which I
don't know how I saw it i blast calm
which I don't know how reliable those
sources are but they have photos from a
security camera so this isn't just like
someone saying son said she said right
right so I was I feel like for some
reason my place is always being
protected by like obviously ABC and then
you know the surrounding just like the
media yeah so when I saw this in page
six today I was very um glad like I was
glad that you know more people are
taking this seriously and writing it up
because I feel like he just gets away
with murder
totally so it's time to hold him
accountable and I will be asking like
vile if he's ever met like Mike Fleiss
because if he ever gets here oh is he
not here yet okay well slow it down then
i was like rushing through cuz i thought
no i feel like he's such an on time I
know he's I'm worried if it's not late
yet not yet bad I got stuck behind a
truck this morning so maybe he owe me
two in my uber literally like went on
the other side of the one way and was
making everyone back up oh well that's
great but this truck for me was
horizontal on a vertical street just
like parked there like unloading we're
thin no way to get either way like how
is that okay
you know I don't know not okay okay
fourth story was the snitch requested
story oh yes and also I need to talk
about Beverly Hills and below deck okay
comes out so yeah don't don't give him a
pen yeah I was about to send it and then
I was like should the snitch text Nick
your name would be the snick Snickers
okay go to the story I'm ready just
kidding
he's actually twice your age yeah no no
no he's not 14 okay Luke Holmes adds
Grand Ole Opry member to list of
accolades country singer Lou Combs was
just six years old when his mom and
grandmother snuck him into his first
concert by hiding him in the back seat
of their car so he could go see Vince
Gill play at a minor-league baseball
stadium it came full circle for singers
for the singer-songwriter from North
Carolina when Gil came out to formally
induct Combs into the Grand Ole Opry on
Tuesday night in Nashville Tennessee
combs who has taken the country music by
stormy webster in the last two
was hit with hit after hit off his major
of off his debut major label record
I'm sorry accounts told him bodging told
reporters backstage before the induction
that he actually didn't get to see Gil
finish that performance 23 years ago
hood I actually missed my favorite song
that night because I started crying
because there was thunder in the
background rain was driving thunder
lightning I'm dead so we ended up
leaving early I am looking forward to
saying hello to him that's the cutest
thing ever it's the most precious gem in
the whole world
comb same two of his hits before gale
and 90s country star Joe Diffie joined
several other opera members on stage for
the induction into the country music
institution Gil praised Combs's
top-notch vocals before joking about
Combs's first introduction to his music
quote I obviously didn't ruin him Gil
said the Opry induction is just the
latest accomplishment from the singer
since releasing his double platinum
album this one's for you in 2017 it
produced five number-one country hits
including four times platinum hurricane
and three times platinum when it rains
it pours I'm just I'm just so happy for
him he's such a precious to have a man
like I was just watching his videos I'm
like he was just so cute and so great
but was like I can't wait to come back
here and play a million more shows and I
was just like me too
I'd like the cutest part and why he's so
precious is because before he like he
did two songs and one after and like the
one after it's like the first song he
sings as an inductive member and so the
first two he's saying when it rains it
pours and beer never broke my heart like
[ __ ] bangers right and then when it
came time for him to sing his song in
the circle as a member of the Opry he's
saying this one's for you and it's just
like that's so precious like he's just
so in tune and Mike I just love him so
much I'm so happy for him like I just
hope that his career literally never
stops which I don't think it will
because every unreleased song he keeps
putting out on his Instagram every
Thursday is so good it's like he does
not have one bad song no and he can't
stop making good music it's like it's
coming out of his [ __ ] veins it's
insane it's insane I'm so happy for him
it's crazy to think about where he is
like in such a short time in the fact
that this one's for you came out in 2017
yet I still listen to it today like it's
the first time I'm hearing it I know you
know and I'm like constantly when I put
him on shuffle like I'm hearing
songs that I just didn't notice before
and now like songs from like 2016 are my
favorite songs like you see you I know
I've been telling you yeah it's I feel
like he released it last week
no and everything is just like what's
the word it's like it's it's time time
timeless yeah
timeless timeless I couldn't agree more
I like his music he's just so good I'm
like the prequel I can't stop listening
to him and then he has a whole album
coming out eventually soon I hope and
it's just like he he legitimately can't
be stabbed I actually think he's like
menachem next Garth Brooks know for sure
and like the also like the groundswell
of support that he has in like the
crowds that he's already playing
stadiums yeah it's insane the people
have spoken and they [ __ ] love when
the people suck in Stannis Baratheon
Luke owns yeah I'm just happy for him
I'm so happy for him and his family and
his fiance and the beautiful life that
the beautiful I think they're gonna have
together yeah this is just so exciting
and so well deserved truly and it almost
feels like this didn't come soon enough
I know right he's just winning Best New
Artist nominated for Best New Artist
like like he's Dylan Neil artists it's
crazy right yeah so I'm really happy for
him and he's such a cutie okay our fifth
and final story which I found
particularly interesting is that so in
honor of exactly 50 years ago today the
Saturn V rocket launched from Kennedy
Space Center Center Kerry Neil Armstrong
Buzz Aldrin and Michael Collins to the
moon that was we went to the moon in
1969 four days later armstrong and
aldrin sorry would land on the moon and
inspire a generation of young people to
become scientists engineers and
mathematicians the Apollo's programs
effect of inspiring America's children
to pursue careers in STEM fields is one
of the most powerful lasting legacies of
the Moon race
unfortunately this effect seems to be
coming to an end on the eve of the
Apollo 11 anniversary leggo asks the
Harris Poll to survey a total of 3,000
children in the United States China and
the United Kingdom about their attitudes
toward and knowledge of space the
results reveal that at least four
Western countries so they asked I don't
want to blow the the very believe yeah
but they did a survey asking
what do you want to be when you grow up
and 29% of kids in the American States
in the United States if they wanted the
American States
29% this was the most popular answer
said they wanted to be youtubers and
bloggers I mean that makes so much sense
to me like those kids all they do is
watch YouTube and 11 percent said they
wanted to be astronauts 26% said they
wanted to be teachers 23% said
professional athletes 19% said musicians
but like the top percent but it's like
when you're a kid you just all you're
doing is dreaming big and all you want
to do is be an astronaut only 11 percent
of kids want to be astronauts now it's
so sad just American camper you know
she's been like working on her YouTube a
little bit yes she's been watching
makeup tutorials ever since she got into
her mom's makeup cabinet but I think
she's more of a consumer of YouTube I
don't know if she like could handle all
the pressure right up starting her own
YouTube channel but I don't know I could
see her going to space like it would be
just like camp an adventure she would
lose her mind space like floating
I can't she would be so sure but
interestingly enough in the United
Kingdom the campers in the United
Kingdom are pretty similar to the u.s.
30 percent wanted to be bloggers and
youtubers well 25 percent teachers 21
percent professional athletes 18 percent
musicians and 11 percent again for
astronauts
now what interests son David age don't
have 20/20 vision
when they ask kids in China you know who
has 20/20 vision you me I should be an
astronaut I would I literally have the
worst vision I could never be an
astronaut no when they ask kids in China
56% said they want to be astronauts 52%
said they want to be teachers 47% said
musicians 37% said professional athletes
and 18%
okay I'm sorry those numbers don't add
up I know that 100% oh yeah I was
thinking the same like how'd it be all
of a sudden go from 29 being the top one
to 56 there must be like some typo no
not a typo but it's like they were able
to pick two or something sorry I know I
agree that was confusing but only 18%
wanna be bloggers in YouTube
okay I'm just like confused now but
that's why we're losing you guys yeah
cuz our kids want to be bloggers and
youtubers and you know it
like we're not setting a great example
because here we are here we are you to
bang I'm surprised I didn't say
podcasters I think I think I think that
like the Jen's ears are they what is
what's below Jen's a I don't know I
don't know whatever though they are like
I don't think answering to podcasts no
not yet but I'm sure these were just the
options given you know yeah yeah no like
where's doctor lawyer I was thinking to
go in the way of the dinosaur show um
anyways I don't know but you guys but I
find this so interesting I mean it's not
the kids fault if they don't want to be
astronaut so if that's not like
lucrative anymore because it used to be
like the biggest baddest thing that we
could do and now we just have other
things but I'm I guess like brand deals
are just so inspiring and it's less work
than being an astronaut yeah it's
lucrative it is lucrative not that I
know but it seems to be what did you
want to be when you grow up a mom and a
cheerleader a mom and a cheerleader I'm
trying to think what I want used to want
me it always was changing I really
always wanted to be a talk show host
ever dude ever not when I was like I
like campers age but when I was like 12
like 12 like high school and up like
that was very like what actually a
journalism major for a hot second no
because Colgate doesn't have a
journalism program which is what I
learned when I got there that there's no
like communications program because I
didn't understand like what liberal arts
meant but it's all the same [ __ ] so
don't worry about it guys unless you
want to be a doctor but even still you
could be like a bio you could go to
Colgate and be a biology major and then
go to medical school so be it doesn't
really matter
yeah unless you're doing something super
specific yeah um so yeah that's what's
going on with America's youth it's grim
there was also another story I want to
talk about that talked about it oh that
we could talk about it okay that um Bill
Gates has been dethroned after seven
years of being the richest man in the
world and the person who took him over
was the Louis Vuitton LBMA yes I thought
that was highly interested and who's he
married to what's his name again
Barnard I had no idea I think he's
married to someone famous bernard arnold
wife yeah never mind sorry false alarm
well that's exciting for him yeah that's
crazy I honestly I don't think Bill
Gates cares I don't think it Bill Gates
cares either and think it's like sad for
Jeff Bezos because he just like oh honey
file is here okay Kyle seriously I've
been here oh I told you he was a prompt
guy Oh totally okay so let's just get
into housewives and belowdecks really
quickly because obviously I need to
recap with Claudia part one of the
reunion of Beverly Hills was on last
night and it really did not disappoint
they did a really good job of addressing
the lack of the elephant in the room the
Lisa Vanderpump of it all and I thought
that Andy was like appropriately savage
because she did not show up for work you
know oh she did not show up for work and
it was an oily interesting episode and I
just I can't say this enough Denise
Richards it's just the unsung hero of
the season and such a welcome addition
to the cast and I like spent a couple of
episodes like talking [ __ ] about her
because I don't care about Charlie Sheen
but now like I care about Denise so I do
want to know about her ex-husband I
don't care that her ex-husband Charlie
Sheen I just want to know about her life
like she's such a precious gem of a
woman she's such a great mother she's a
good friend and she's just a cool girl
and she's really done a great job of
like bringing something to the show that
we didn't already have there you know
yeah so we're gonna get into puppy heat
like next week which is gonna be
interesting
I feel I'm sorry is it kind of boring
because LBP isn't there like yeah
because now it's we're kind of just like
a little chamber inside but now we're
getting into the weeds a little bit with
like teddy because she always admitted
that she was ready to like you know [ __ ]
with Dury but then she like decided not
to do it because she realized LBP was
gonna pin it all on her yeah but they're
going into like why were you so ready
willing and able to do that you know not
it so it'll be it'll be interesting to
say the least
I don't know it's really a great night
of television for me because I got to
catch up on below deck I'm still
watching love island for some odd reason
and I've really been enjoying Green Chef
which for those of you who don't know
green
is a wonderful wonderful meal kit at
home
program that lets you choose from a wide
array of easy to follow lifestyles with
select organic ingredients and green
chef is now owned by hellofresh
in order to offer wider array of meal
plans to choose from there's something
for everyone you can switch between like
green chef hellofresh whatever you want
but green chef has really specific
dietary needs
paleo plant power - vegan and vegetarian
pescetarian keto gluten-free omnivore so
for me I love this keto and I love
pescetarian I feel as though a kosher
yes sometimes I identify as vegetarian
but pescetarian is really what I am I
eat fish and vegetables yes so I love
that how specific it is I've been
ordering the pescetarian version and
it's truly delicious green chef's expert
chefs design flavorful recipes to your
lifestyle that go way beyond ordinary
substitutions they have a diverse array
of meal plans with plenty of options to
choose from each week so you can
actually enjoy sticking to your goals
you can enjoy clean ingredients you can
trust
seasonally sourced for peak freshness
after this weekend of dirty eating like
clean eating has been exactly what I
needed
so I whipped up some green chef and I
popped in the Hospice of Beverly Hills
and honestly was a premium evening for
me wow I'm really jealous so if you guys
want to try green chef which I highly
recommend you can go to green chef dot
US fresh toast 75 there you will get a
total of seventy five dollars off that's
twenty-five dollars off each of your
first three boxes at green chef dot us
slash toasts seventy-five once again
that's green chef dot us slash toast
seventy-five honestly it's a wonderful
meal program for people with specific
dietary needs which is me like all the
time and I just I can't recommend it
enough and it really helps you get your
foot wet in the cooking world I get my
foot wet speaking of getting your foot
wedded cooking world below deck we have
a new chef and this episode the queen of
Versailles you remember I haven't
watched documentary I just know I know
that I have to watch it base okay well
she's on board and they're definitely
hyenas but they also have a heart of
gold which I think we also was clear
from [ __ ] alright you got it
Wow sorry that was like murder
a live murder live which was clear in
the documentary like the fact that
they're super outrageous but they're
kind of a nice family and like even when
they were going through it I don't want
to spoil the documentary but like I'm
really gonna watch it and I think
everyone here they have a really nice
just family dynamic um
and the Queen herself Jackie is really
interesting like as a woman because
she's not what you think she's gonna be
so I really enjoyed I'm enjoying them as
guests the drama is heating up what is
going on with the new third stew like I
think I don't know it's weird because
she I like her but there's suddenly a
weird vibe shape woke up in the middle
of the night and ate a whole cake
because she forgot to have dinner like
okay I will never understand people who
forget to eat their meals but I'm like I
don't never understand people who forgot
to eat their meals like it's just it's
so like I live my life based on what is
my next meal no totally it's lemon lime
and make a wish justice in peace for
Laura place yeah so is gonna see and
like a clean break clean break I hope he
doesn't make her like a living out in
court yeah I'm in life I hope we all
make his life living how first um I
think getting like so bad I'm
remembering my like thoughts about TV
but then I also feel like it's because
there's nothing really I have so more
time remembering my thoughts about
things that are like that happened like
yesterday like I just I can't remember
anything it's like it's just getting so
much worse my memory yeah I feel that
also Camille came on in Beverly Hills
she's coming out guns blazing I ready to
be a full-time housewife next season you
know is she I don't know if I would
announce yet know that we won't know for
a while but I saw that OC super soon
it's crazy how like they just sneak up
on you I'm excited for Dallas it looks
like everyone has like new fresh faces
and it love that yeah and like cam and
Leeanne are fighting and I'm ready for
the turn tiss you know okay so I think
it's time to bring out any file right
yeah I think it's time we get ready he's
got some questions we got some questions
and you know we can talk about all these
things that we're talking about just
with him so we will see you soon
or get a snack or a drink and then come
like your presets Jackie Afflick summer
pack it's here it's popping it's on see
ya
you
welcome back to the morning toasts we
are here with Nick vile ah once twice
three times a charm best friends I know
you're like our official bachelor
correspondent you just go check yeah
this is where I feel like you have
really great insights you're also in the
podcasting realm so like it's never
painful you come a long way we've come
so far you guys anything can happen
it's amazing it's like Megan Markel from
Deal or No Deal to Princess us this is
up there this is my she's got princess
status but I feel like we were a close
second we won a one it's one of those
just like miracles of the world so
welcome to New York welcome back to the
toast always gonna be here my family
what are you in town for what brings you
to town I had to well the morning toast
of course but I did some kind of
bachelor GMA recap with Rachel Lindsay
ah we have a picture of you guys yeah we
accidentally coordinated polka dots
right that's Rachel's great she's always
fun to catch up with her and we have
she's like really good at having debates
she's a lawyer she's smart and she's so
smart and like we and it was kind of
like even on my season like we just
always had great conversations okay just
kind of always like a really healthy
discussion with her and so it's always
fun to see her that's so fun do you ever
get tired of talking about The Bachelor
sure yeah well we're going to talk about
it it's fine but like yeah it's a great
season yes so is there an agreement yeah
this is an amazing season and I said the
best season ever
for The Bachelor I mean again ferritin
fairness I only started watching
Desiree's season and after I didn't
watch it before I was ever on easily the
best Bachelorette season it's I like
it's different because it's just like
it's just a really good real season like
there are other seasons that were like
like I love Jojo season yeah like I love
like Rachel's but this is just different
this is a different Bachelorette season
than I've ever seen
I think Kaitlyn's was the closest I mean
it's equal because like Hannah's got a
lot of like slut-shaming yeah and I saw
a lot of tweets yesterday like Kaitlyn
had to walk before Hannah could run and
there's some truth to that in terms of
like progress that's true I look at the
Bachelorette and bachelor very
differently just because of how the men
and women
so I kind of compare them differently
but the best Bachelorette I think what
do you think it's different about this
season that makes it so much better
well because I think like Luke Luke is a
real villain Leah and other seasons you
kind of have I don't wanna say made-up
villains but like no one's really that
bad yeah sometimes you just don't get
along with people but Luke is he's a
real villain and she really likes him it
was so great surprise yeah and that
that's what makes it compelling cuz it's
not like a lot of a lot of questions
like oh did you really keep them from
right now she's keeping him along and
she's like he would have won like it was
his to lose he lost and that's what
makes it so compelling religious
impression rose and like everyone who
gets the first impression rose on the
Bachelorette he's always the one who
wins like he yeah yeah yeah right yeah
he could have and should have win but he
literally like dug his grave like he is
saying it's so insane and he's like he's
very religious he's a young guy and so
is Hanna so like there's this whole
conflict between like religion and kind
of progress and like sex and sacks and
so what's makes Hannah I love Hannah
because she talks about her religion
whether you agree with it or not but
like you commend her for like being
strong with her religion but also like
being progressive in the fact that like
so this whole like conundrum that she's
facing between like faith in progress
and like you see her constantly fighting
it I think it's fascinating right very
like real world right it's very little
of the time yes totally
that is super interesting well my
husband always says any superhero movie
is only as good as its villain so I
guess that applies to The Bachelor and
it is he might be the best villain of
all time
yeah Wow okay honestly you're getting me
super jazz we have so many questions for
you but right now what's going on is
like everyone's coming out with their
like ex-girlfriend stories and like
dumping girls to go on the show
what are your Sean I okay Jed's
ex-general no no like there was just an
article that came out so yeah the tooth
the jet of the Peter story they're
they're completely different but I go
180 from it yeah like Jed from what the
reports say is that he went on with a
girlfriend he had a girlfriend he he
said it was for the show
he told her to wait he was like saying I
love you there's a love letter on the
napkin right that's the people I've
sentence over people no one's delusional
enough to like they don't know one goes
on just for love like no one's that
desperate like there's plenty of ways to
meet people you go on if the experience
open to meet like open to the experience
the experiences maybe finding love right
what Peter broke up allegedly like four
months before the show was casted it's
in December so he's like there's a zero
chance he was casted in December so all
he knew at best was maybe it was a
possibility even if they said like
listen we really like you we think this
could be a possibility they said that a
lot of people who never get on right and
so like they broke up like people break
up all the time and like this we took a
vacation together or like we said I love
you listen it sucks and I feel bad for
her but like people like say I love you
and break up people take vacation people
might say and joke our kids would be so
cute together
they break up still wait and that sucks
and I'm sorry her feelings are hurt but
like it's a totally 180 and I also think
that it's at the timings poor taste like
if it was that come out with it I know
she had mentioned it and it was kind of
floating out there but like really the
Monday of fantasy suites like at the end
of season clearly she's pissed he's got
all this attention and like this Peter 4
batch they're talking like yeah that's
salty move it's a salty move she should
be the bachelor I think Mike Peter Tyler
could all be an option certainly not
Chad I hated so much of the burning
passion but not even because of the
girlfriend like I just can't stand him
you bothers me so much do you think do
you think that it's like do you think
you like objectively say that because
like I didn't love like it's like
underlying um maybe not but like I think
that this story made me open my eyes to
how much I could write and then ever
since then they constantly say implanted
guitar it's obsessive it's just like I
came from music where's my guitar like
is there a piano it's like it's so
aggressive and like once we knew the the
rumors it just made it ten times worse
that's fair
well like I feel like if he came out
like that viciously about like Tyler or
Peter like I would still like kind of
like I would still be like secretly
for them but like just knowing that like
they probably aren't gonna make all
right yeah like a listen if Peter had a
girlfriend like Jed I would be just as
critical and if Tyler even if you broke
up with this alleged girlfriend like the
night before certainly Porteous a bad
timing but at least he broke up like
going single yeah oh yeah that's all
right that's all you have to do think
the one requirement is like be single be
single like that's it like have a clean
break I mean the Peter story like one
thing is clear is they broke up right
like how long you have to be broken up
with so before you go on the show so
totally different I'm team Peter Adams
big team Peter I'm 18 Peter and Tyler I
like it I've met them both both nice
guys
Peter got the whole pilot thing it's
great yeah Tyler's just pretty and nice
yeah yeah no I like see his like
shirtless pictures and my I don't follow
him in my facebook from the group so
I've heard good things
okay there's been a lot of bachelor news
this week first up Welles and Sarah
argue very exciting we're so happy for
that another one boys that does I'm
happy for them I mean Sarah's great hung
out with him a few times Welles as a
friend so it's awesome ya know it's
definitely like I'm jealous but yeah
same and same they are super cute and
like normal-seeming like everything has
just been like yeah greatly timed like
scene same yeah for me everything I
don't hang out with I'm a ton but
they're they're just a normal couple
really cute okay speaking of another
couple yesterday we reported that Kaylin
and Dean your friend Dean are dating it
was a weird way the news came out though
because it's like not a bachelor in
paradise spoiler but it is it would be
right even she didn't even mention that
they met in paradise they were just
talking about d-ends it was like an e
news it's interesting because I feel
like the franchise in general and this
is not something like I'm just as
basically what I observe they're less
worried about paradise spoilers yeah
yeah cuz there's so many storylines even
if it was so many storylines like I
I must I don't know for sure but I'm
assuming Dean's not engaged you know
it's so like if he's not and there are
other engagements in Paris if they
happen I don't really know anything I
just know there was drama and Blake's
part of it he's like it's a new D I feel
like he's won up to Dean and that
department
yeah well we got some questions about
that cuz people wanted to know your
thoughts cuz I guess you've been public
like a little shady towards him be Blake
please please don't once on a comment
like yeah he made a post and I'm like I
heard you really made your mark
literally or something it was like a
kind of a reference listen I I don't
I've met Blake he's a nice guy we don't
hang out if what we hear is true like
does that make him a bad guy no but it
doesn't make them very smart about like
like what were you thinking man like
yeah you know no totally yeah and like I
don't know how it's gonna go but like if
it's kind of what we hear and if it's
similar to a Dean where he's as he had
maybe too much fun like listen it's all
consensual there's two parties here
right women and men both do an
imagination it can be a bit incestuous
but but also like in Dean's defense like
if he was only juggling between two
girls you really like that became it's
like juggling between relationships this
was like one weekend for girls like yeah
well again that's what I honor a little
bit understand is like Dean was juggling
too it's like it's weird they're just
different right like one you could argue
the Dean thing is bad cuz it's like
you're kind of messing with these girls
who both think there's a chance of a
relationship or from what I gather from
the Blake stuff he just was like [ __ ]
around [ __ ] around
yeah I can you know like is that a crime
to go to a concert and hook up no I mean
like that's smart he was going to write
yeah I get what point today everyone
just do you think they were just gonna
pretend it didn't happen right
especially if you decided to date
someone like but yeah yeah buddy
again it won't look good it doesn't make
him a bad guy but I bet it won't be
great TV oh my god yeah I'm really
jazzed for paradise this season like I
just feel like it's gonna follow suit
with the seasons of The Bachelorette and
just be like the best whatever it could
be for sure
I mean I think I think it's not gonna be
boring did you go down to Paradise at
all for any filming I did not know yeah
I kind of stay yeah I mean when the
franchise helped ask me to I was gonna
go to the wedding
yeah just but I just didn't work out but
like I'm happy to support the franchise
when I can but try to stay away yeah no
one's gonna find myself in a situation
where it looks like I'm trying to go on
when I'm not right understood well we
also had some other bachelor news say
because Mike Fleiss is in the news for
being you know sorry have you met him I
have a few times but I don't have a much
of a relationship with him he's pretty
hands-off at this point and he has been
for a while as my understanding I don't
know him very well I mean obviously the
reports and great right I yeah I hope
they figure it out he's hands-off and it
shouldn't be it's hard to get rid of him
I don't know how that works right
because of the creator
cuz he's like yeah but whatever that
cool obviously upsetting stuff and
honestly not good for the franchise
especially when it's a relationship show
right talking about right especially
like with the Hannah stuff and women
empowerment and a lot of progressiveness
yeah hopefully hopefully yes this is sir
yeah sure
whatever that looks like okay we have so
many questions for you and I'm actually
really interested because you've been
podcasting now for a good how many
months now six months we're coming up on
our 30th episode it's pretty cool since
January so oh seven months perfect so
what has been losing your favorite guest
most interesting
most interesting I got I mean it seems
almost like low-hanging fruit but Hannah
really you know in terms of the most
interesting like I had met her she's
obviously the current Bachelorette and I
had high expectations of her and she
didn't disappoint like even in a podcast
especially like in interviews you know
they can be a little reserved there's
some guy and I knew that so I didn't
want to ask I didn't like our podcast I
was like I don't care about what
happened this season I don't care what
spoilers let's get to know you and she
was really interesting and forthcoming
and she's definitely someone who just
kind of says and then things later which
is just really great and interesting and
so I thought that was it was a lot of
fun my absolutely drops today shameless
plug is sex with Emily she has a big sex
podcast and she was really fun and
interesting Jay Glazer was a friend and
she's a comedian and she was a ton of
fun so those prime months three of my
favorites I have a question for you I
know something like guys think about cuz
I I just think about it some weird so
now that your season has coming on and
you've seen all the girls on your season
like what they do on Instagram and where
everyone's sort of landed is there
anyone that you wish you had given
deeper consideration to at the time oh
good question
no and like nothing no disrespect to any
of the women I said this yesterday like
Rachael was probably like even
throughout the season my best friend and
I definitely got along with her the best
and we had the best like connection in
terms of just like getting along and
talking
I just don't think is corny as that
might sound that my person was casted
and that happens some seasons you know
and that's okay it's not a big deal but
like again like Vanessa I definitely
weren't meant to be together
but I was definitely into her for better
or worse when it was filming and like
those were real feelings and that's all
you can really do the women are great
but like there's there's definitely not
a shoot I should have that is good
because you don't want to have regrets
but I feel like sometimes you get didn't
you see so much about what people are
about after the show you know what is it
total do they go like what are they
doing for work like what are their
instant
make sure it's like what's there been
deleted yeah not that not that I would
necessarily have the opportunity but if
I felt that way I would certainly look
into it haven't and I don't plan to okay
that's good to know
so when is a Shane shards wedding I
should probably know that date nation
it's in Rhode Island there's a lot of
fun I'm standing up it should be a lot
of fun like Ben will be there and Dean
have you met Ben's new girlfriend
I have not so I'll meet her for the
first time I'm assuming she'll be there
I hear she's lovely it should be a lot
of fun it's obviously a she and Jared
over the years I mean there probably are
my closest friends I mean I'm really
close with a lot of people but a
shinjiru probably it got to the point
where you know sometimes you have like
friends and you're they're cool hangs
and you but ash and Jared are type of
friends were if I'm like stressing or I
have a problem
like I'll vent to them and I'll trust
their advice and vice versa and I'll
tell them intimate things and trust them
with stuff as opposed to like other
people it's like it's good to see you
yeah yeah are you Grimson yeah well
that's a real I treat you black my event
hopefully it's not hot right will be
yeah I don't know it could be one of
those like weekends it's just in August
I've never been to Rhode Island I hear
it's pretty it's like apparently the
fancy part of Rhode Island that's
exciting
no I think Rhode Island is very nice and
I was just in like Massachusetts which
is New England I it's kind of close
right I'm supposed to fly oh yeah yeah
it's very nice there yeah and there's
some drama with Vanessa not being
invited I don't think so I don't exactly
thank you you're a spot that comment I'm
like they were not she doesn't actually
season Jared and Vanessa do a podcast
together
oh they're co-worker anything whether
you invite your co-workers to your
wedding is it though I think normal
people struggle with that a lot because
it's like you see them every day but do
you are you friends with them but now
podcast is a different level
thank God she you know she lives in
Montreal I think I'm pretty sure and
again Ivan wasn't really involved that
that's the most important thing is I had
nothing to do with it
my only frustration at the time it
seemed like there was like this
implication that I was a reason why she
was not yes I have joked that like
listen invite her she has a boyfriend
now
great Instagram I'm a moment I'll be in
the background with her I'll get like a
hundred thousand likes for sure like oh
my god there's a no-lose situation and
I'm like I have no hard feelings or
anything it's not awkward like I would
love to meet her boyfriend so like my
understanding is they're just not close
yes it's a small enough wedding and so
like it's inviting close friends are you
bringing a date no like I I think I
would be able to if I was in a serious
committed relationship but I'm not and
again it's in Rhode Island I feel like
you really got to be in a relationship
to bring someone to a destination yeah
yeah you're kind of setting some pretty
big expectations yeah like you know date
one of someone for like two weeks but
there's this like wedding across the
country it's like one like then all of a
sudden like one room traveling together
it's like scary right your break and
like I better view into her right might
better not ruin your good time you know
it's too much pressure
yeah and then like again I know it's for
that reason I think invitations are
tight so I'm not gonna burden it is a
DTV wedding no I think it's it's a
bashing Jarrod plant I mean they have a
wedding planner yeah everything but they
did this all on their own and the
bachelor there's a lot of producers
going there close friends with but it's
not like a bachelor show or sponsored
but like that yeah that's really sweet
that sounds feeling I think they run it
wanted their own wedding I mean I think
they might have had an opportunity to
like kind of do the whole bachelor
wedding bachelor in paradise thing in
Mexico but what is been very right like
Jaden Tanner's wedding that was a
awesome real wedding yeah other weddings
I've been to they're they're nice but
they're and it's you don't necessarily
get full say over everything Ashley and
Jared just wanted their wedding and
that's what they
yes she seems like she knows what she
wants when it comes to her wedding she's
very specific yeah it's very specific um
interesting question if you could play
matchmaker with someone from a previous
any season of bachelor nation with
Hannah who do you think that she would
have measured out with yes you know do
you have any suggestions well now I have
to think back to like previous season
definitely not Blake definitely and that
Blake might have been a nice choice I
think everyone was shipping them
hardcore and I guess things went down
now Jason is have you met him I have
nice guy yeah like I'm drawing a blank
on like who's even around or so many
people have like just expose themselves
as like men you know yeah listen I
always say no one's as good or as bad on
that show like all jokes aside I've met
Tyler right in a sense it's very pretty
but like this like adoration is getting
he's a guy yeah you know and if you met
him at a bar yeah yeah that's a
good-looking guy you know many nights
yeah and the people who like for Blake
is a perfect example like you look at
Blake last year on Becca season and it
was like oh like he's so sweet he can't
do any wrong and I liked him and I met
him but I kind of would roll my eyes
with this like he's perfect I'm like I
am certain he's not yeah he's just a guy
yeah and it's the same with the women
too like we all do things that if you
had a put on her lens could be
criticized but yeah you know if Hanna if
this doesn't work out with you here with
these rumors like oh yeah I don't know
for sure don't explain
oh no one knows for sure that's what I
told you but like you know the Peter
stuff I don't know how she would feel
about that or you know like what Mike I
don't know for sure I've heard multiple
rumors so it's the first time I've been
unspoiled but I would it looks like
she's gonna pick jad that's what I said
but now I don't know because it looks
like you know we have no no spoiler but
first I wouldn't think it was
right Luke was the one that she was like
I'm in love with right but then when
they were giving him the villain edit it
was like she didn't sleep with Tyler and
not that she can't get engaged to him
but like yeah I feel like she did sleep
with Peter she did which I was surprised
cuz up into this point it was like Peter
was just kind of like floating along
agreed and then but like Jed she's is
like she told him she loves him she told
him she's a follower though like you can
tell she cares what he says like she's
and you see that with the lead when they
start like worrying about what they
think then you can tell they're invested
yeah other than Luke it's only been Jed
so if the rumors are true and she picks
Jed I don't oh you mean the rumors about
the girlfriend Oh true what happened yes
like would you like you do you stay with
a guy who came into this and lied to you
because like you know you need Jesus but
like in one of his first dates he was
like had he to tell you something I just
want to be upfront when I first came on
this season I came from a music girl I'm
just gonna be real with you right and
she was like oh well that sucks but
thank you for being so honest and like
even I kind of was like oh whatever but
like a lot of batch ination was like you
know what good for you for finally
owning up to it but it turns out if the
rumors are true it was just a half truth
which makes it worse it's like if a guy
goes to Vegas on her Bachelor party he
has a girlfriend
and he ends up having sex with any
cheats on his wife right he comes home
he feels really bad and he's like hey
babe I need to be honest with you I met
one girl nothing happened but like I
flirted with her and I felt guilty and
even that felt wrong and I did do that
but I just want you know nothing having
meanwhile he totally [ __ ] her yeah and
he's just like kind of owning up to a
little bit so it seems like she can
trust them and the people who do that
are cut extra shady it's like an
awareness that you're yeah it's like and
if the rumors are true and she ends up
with Jed how do you stay with this guy I
don't know I don't know anyways
can't wait to finale that is so crazy
but also you said that she slept with
Peter but now we know that sometimes
that the show makes it look like people
have slept together when they haven't so
how do we have come but she I mean she
kind of said we [ __ ] in the wind
mizuno guy okay there are pretty much
confirmed okay
for example we don't know we assume she
slept with dad but we don't that's why
yeah we know she didn't sleep with Tyler
because she said she didn't but so
that's that's what we know we know she
had sex with Peter we think she had sex
with Chad and we know she didn't have
sex with Tyler and she sent Luke home
okay so yeah we don't know for sure but
this that's what was so interesting with
this episode it wasn't Santa suits most
yours are like what you think we're
having sex and it's really about the
relationship
this episode was who was Hannah gonna
[ __ ] titles like on my god whose it was
wild I thought it was great I said good
for the show for making it more like
real and like people it's like gone are
the days were you like thinking you like
kind of roll your eyes we know what's
going on why don't they talk about it
yeah they're finally like talking about
it and like you got to give Hannah some
credit for being open to talk about it
some of it is people are afraid to do
that because they're afraid of what the
criticism you know that is that's pretty
cool with her yeah she's she's pretty
cool sometimes in you okay
I'm gonna watch snitch I'm gonna
binge-watch it all before paradise well
thank you so much for being here and I
have to tell you again that I love your
essential oils I use them on the plane I
use your diffuser
I like crack open I know I'm so excited
and you have a promo code for the
toasters but I cracked open one of the
oil support into the diffuser but then I
just like and then I think you're good
at don't do it use the ones I sent you
the pure ones the concentrated oils for
the diffuser I only have the rollers I
sent you those really then I must have
missed it in the package I'll send you
some more okay thank you because the
roll are diluted with jojoba oil so
they're safe to put a reclaim your skin
so like you don't want to and it's so
they're less concentrated but just
enough you're perfect for an amount for
your skin because essential oils are
very potent strong so they absorb right
in your body and in the the diffuser you
want to put the pure essential oils that
don't have a home oil in it guys I
haven't put pure on my skin I just
fittings rollers or okay sweet some more
big fan what is the code for toasters
codes toasters 35% off which I've never
do but I love the toasters I love you
and I really
love your essential oils like I'm Aiman
oils knows it now I love it thanks so
much
hoi Khanh NH oils calm I had they
recommend such of you in your anxiety
that I gotta get on smooth like you so
you put them free shipping Donnelly I
mean there's not really no reason why
not deny three five percent off it's lit
well thank you so much for being so I'm
gonna see you again so much fun per
usual we only back tomorrow hopefully
Claudia will be back hopefully she's
feeling better thank you all for being
here switch thank you for filling in
hosting wannabes I'm where can ever
unfollow you I think we all do but just
me
oh yeah Nick file Instagram vial files
is the podcast you're gonna follow that
natural habit and Instagram for if the
oils there you go and we'll see you
tomorrow have a great day bye
you